please to have here on the rich eyes and
show Patrick Korbin how are you sir yeah
great guys how are you I'm doing great
how's life ah pretty awesome it's good
to hear here that will champion so still
getting used to but I think it's very
exciting week for us is it true you
didn't start playing organized ball I
mean seriously until middle of high
school Patrick is that a fact yeah I
played I played our colonel for a
basketball team in 11th grade and some
of the guys on the team played baseball
and I played Little League here and
there other positions I was a
left-handed catcher the left hand sort
stop things like that and but some of
the the basketball guys were like hey
you aren't you just try out and and I
did and said on the pitch and never hit
in high school to pitch and that was it
okay so my eight-year-old who does use
his left hand to throw a baseball you're
saying I've got a chance I've got a shot
here Patrick so what you're saying right
now it definitely helps us I can't tell
you when he picked up a ball as a you
know as a three-year-old and started
throwing it with his left hand I thought
to myself there's 40 years of viability
left in that arm that's exactly what I
thought yeah no it's definitely getting
like my dad was a lefty so he's [ __ ]
my slider grip and look when I was a kid
and I used today so that's always
remember so when did you begin to sense
Patrick that something special could
happen on this team began the season
where things are going our way again
playing good baseball yeah we had a lot
of injuries I mean the whole top of our
lineup was hurt and I knew from Spring
Training we played well we had players
that that were good enough to win it we
had a lot of veterans in that Clubhouse
of young players that were good that
something's got to turn around we're
just too good and a couple of guys and
started playing better and and kind of
healthy and we said from that moment if
we can just get into the playoffs we
could be very dangerous so there wasn't
really one moment or one stretch in a
season where you started looking around
and saying okay
where we have a we're arriving right now
yeah yeah I mean I think after that that
start over in 1931 we played the best
baseball in MLB so there is a stretch in
there where we felt things were changing
we knew our goal is to get a couple
games over 500 around the all-star break
and we felt the momentum after that and
time has rolled with it
Patrick I gave you two chances for you
to say the words baby shark and you
didn't I gave two shots right there with
partner I mean I played a part in
Arizona I mean he was obviously a huge
piece for us to loosen things up bring
some energy in a dugout and he was he
was for sure a huge piece for us he came
in when we did have injuries he stepped
right and played played centerfield for
us hit really well and just what was the
reaction though the first time did
everyone know that he was gonna have
baby shark played as his walk up song
when he switched to that was that a
winner that already or your Clubhouse
already aware of that um no we had no
idea until the first time I went on I
think one of his kids will love the song
and I mean every kid does I guess they
were just like let's throw all of it
they started playing it and then you
just know action on the fans and doing
it and then it just kind of built up
after that and I think people are
discovering games to see him pinch-hit
ladies I know but there was no sense in
the in the dugout like as he came back
in after that at-bat saying what the
hell was that it definitely caught on
really quick though you know after the
first one it was like over this and fans
got it right away and then it was pretty
neat in the postseason when you saw a
packed stadium everyone doing it
Nationals pitcher game 7 winner Patrick
Korbin here on the Rich Eisen show ok so
you're out there in the pen Game seven
when did you get a sense you might be in
this foot in that baseball game we knew
max
was coming off that neck and back injury
and and we weren't really sure what what
he was going to be able to do so I just
tried to stay loose loose the whole time
and I thought whenever he was
maybe I don't have a chance to come in
and he got through five innings got some
trouble and pitched out of it and kept
us in the game and they called down and
told me I was in and I had no idea if it
was gonna be one batter a couple or end
up going three innings
so you're you'd stroll in here it is in
the middle of after the bottom five you
stroll in and you're taking the mound
top six down to nothing in Houston
people going crazy this they're sensing
the moment what are you thinking I guess
it's a big moment but I try not thinking
about that you just try to go out there
try to be prepared focus on your job and
I think I'll look back and see how cool
that was to pitch him in Game seven but
I felt pretty good I mean the whole that
whole month we are in big situations
like that played in some big stadiums
where fans were loud getting going nuts
so we just felt like if we just if I
could just throw up zeroes there keep us
in the game our offense been doing it
all your plate right then you stroll out
there bottom seven now you got a lead I
mean talk about a switch you're down
here your team's down in the last eight
outs and now suddenly it's up to you to
start making sure that the Astros last
nine outs go quickly walk me through
that mindset as Kendrick put one off the
foul pole yeah I mean Holly and just
can't be happy nice person he's been
doing it all season for us and like I
said I think if I put up a zero there in
the six gives it offense another chance
over close this one does it's on a
homework and tie it so when they are
offenses to do to sit down Greinke was
unbelievable he he D F a homer curve and
down and then walk the guy and they they
got him out of there but that's kind of
what we've been doing all Peter Patrick
Korbin Nationals pitcher here on the
Rich Eisen show who what's with the
shirts off celebration where did this
come from
just just sometimes take it off when we
were celebrating in the clubhouse it
started happening and they need
it started happening that's one way to
put it and then he did a bony thing you
know I mean I noticed he did it after
the parade you know at the podium and I
said that his wife was getting and then
and then the sweaters if you will come
off on the ice on the Zamboni with the
caps were you one of those guys on the
Zamboni yes I was one and we're told
strictly to keep our seat but there's
seatbelts on that thing even though it's
looking really swell and they said we
couldn't stand up so we also had some
thanks we have the trophy with us and
we're just like that but I guess they're
gonna kick us off hey you win the World
Series and the things going what like
eight miles an hour I think you know you
got the trophy with you it's one of
those where you ask for forgiveness I
think rather than permission Patrick
don't you think yeah I think the head
guy there we took a photo with a master
in May things up but fans are loving it
all the height the hockey players were
into our ski there all year and we've
been into theirs who was the dude from
the Nationals who took his shirt off and
then Ovechkin jumped on his back who's
that fellow BP thrower so it's kind of a
little celebration that we do and that
was pretty cool if you can do that you
know no offense to ollie but he took his
shirt off and he still had a sweater on
I think Patrick yeah okay you just want
to make sure that that's uh don't adjust
your sets have to have that layered
effect so you're from you're from the
upstate New York area is that where
you're from
okay from Syracuse New York so does this
mean you're a Bills fan what's your
football leave this Patrick lately Venna
just my fantasy team but I grew up at
the I go I said okay I got a follow up
on that how
Jaguars fans sitting there in Syracuse
New York is that is that a Coughlin
thing maybe um well kinda I did like him
but I I got I starting into the NFL when
they came out at 95 it's this kind of
stupid women I got a couple brothers is
in assists there we all have different
teams and those kind of similar thing
like that okay and in terms of growing
up a baseball fan is it true you Patrick
Korbin were a Yankee fan is that a true
story yeah for sure heavy every kid that
I grew up with and my parents everybody
Yankee fans okay
are you aware that most Yankee fans
wanted you to sign with the Yankees in
the last year are you aware that most
Yankee fans thought that you were going
to sign with the Yankees last year I
know that's two separate questions but
you may answer both yeah for sure I mean
I did say a couple of things I grew up a
fan and people kind of blew that up but
kind of had the opportunity to commune
in good situations widely and it would
have been cool to say that I was a
Yankee but I think I made the right list
I like coming to Washington oh no we did
Patrick I'm not saying that you made a
wrong maneuver at all I mean just an
understand I'm from Staten Island New
York Reggie Jackson and and that 70s
team caused me to fall in love with
baseball Don Mattingly is my favorite
player of all time so this does come
from a very personal point of view
did they not come up with the scratch is
that what happened or what what's the
scoop there they were like dialog
between other teams and they were kind
of a little bit off and I said we wanted
to go somewhere where we felt felt
comfortable and a team that was gonna
win and obviously New York would've done
that and in Washington was another place
and they were a little off from some of
those teams and I mean that's kind of
what it is now it's kind of what it is
and now you're sure it was some a
Zamboni lifting a trophy I understand
that's the way life works sometimes huh
I mean I'm sure you guys watched
I mean at least that postseason run that
we had and just a real Patrick I gotta
tell you man it was a you know I I do
believe there are baseball gods I do
believe it and that sometimes the
baseball gods put a little bit of a
thumb on the scale and the way that you
performed for much of the season after
you mentioned that 19 and 31 start the
way that that you won the wild-card game
against Milwaukee the way that you wound
up boat racing your way essentially into
the World Series and and and everything
else caused me to believe that there was
something going on there with your team
yes yeah for sure I mean one thing
doesn't go our way I mean we could have
got out of that wild-card game that
fault goes right to them it kicks left
and gets by himself
that's right and if the Steinbrenner had
only kicked over a rock and done what
they should have done with you you never
know but that's just me easy buddy I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
hey Patrick congratulations to you I
hope this is the first of many times
that we get to chat on this show and
beyond right back at you that's Patrick
Korbin for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app